look at how [ __ ] beautiful nature is
Wow nature oh my God how about your team
Julia I'm on your team bro Twitter down
eh now I know where the holes came from
the wall God damn dude
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of late careful boys
today we got Jesus in the building
what's up Jesus
but we also have
sorry a crowd favorite everybody's
giving up for Julia gulia
what's up
I don't know I don't know well okay so
so I think the last time I was here I
was telling you guys that I was like
starting to get into hiking that's
wonderful yeah um so wonderful it's
great and then and then um I I went to
Washington uh for a bachelorette party
and I decided to go a week early so that
could explore the wonderful state of
Washington by yourself Yeah Yeah by
myself but I was like staying at a
friend's house like completely different
group though but yeah and so I was like
all right I definitely want to go on a
hike at least five miles because I
brought my stupid Hydra pack because I
packed my super Hydra pack I need to at
least go on a hike what's a hydro pack
it's just like a backpack
hello I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody
I've got so Furious dude I was like dude
shut up it's like sorry mixed language
is fanny pack but water into your mouth
oh and you decided to go hiking alone
uh yeah I guess that was mistake number
one yeah you never go alone yeah see I
was not in that memo of hiking 101 where
you always hike with a partner but I had
people know where I was like yeah see I
do that too like by yourself you hike by
yourself
but I also hiking in more populated
areas without like running
I think that's called being homeless I
go to Studio City oh
I always hike armed hike it's like
nothing incense and then Julia so yeah
so um I I get there and I'm like Okay
cool so I'm looking at places of where I
could hike and initially I was supposed
to hike with my friends but they were
like oh we can't do the hike today
because
um we want to take like our sister over
and like she has work there today and
like the amount of time wouldn't work
out and I was like that's fine we can do
something else and so because I had all
day Sunday so I arrived Saturday I had
all day Sunday to go on a hike and I
picked out a hike and I was like cool
I'm gonna go to Mount Rainier I'm gonna
check out this hike and I was like this
is a six and a half mile hike uh it's a
Day hike and it says it'll take me about
like four hours to do this is why it
takes an hour for her to tell the story
no I love it
details dude you jerk Joe's like this is
the longest I can pay attention to
something
do you or do you not want a story I want
a story why don't you play with your
comb again
Okay so
I'm driving there right and it says it's
like 60 miles right and like holy shit's
house it said it would take two hours
right I was like 60 miles and when
you're here in California it's like 60
miles like you could probably get it
done like yeah like an hour like maybe
like an hour 15 right it said two hours
to get there and I was like what the
[ __ ] like that that's not right right I
get there and I know why it's two
[ __ ] hours because as soon as like
the pavement was gone I hit gravel like
I hit like a dirt road like there was
rocks the size of my head two hours
that's why my family got here in America
yep
paved roads paid roads it slowed you
down yes let me know so I was literally
like getting there like at 10 miles an
hour and it was like 14 miles of that
[ __ ] and then as soon as I get to the
trail it was already like 2 p.m I know I
left really like that's another hiking
rule you messed up woke up okay look
here's the thing I wait but it was gonna
take four hours to do the hike so you
were gonna arrive at 2 p.m yeah oh my
God finish that okay let's say you get
like 2 30 like but then you still have
to come back yep yeah driving back is
it's not it's not a wrap around right it
was like you go for two hours and you
have to come back for another two hours
oh yeah that's a four hour hike hey
mistakes were made but okay right but
this is a great story okay sorry it's
not a loop issues do you have one do you
have a destination you come back as in
me yeah we are interested we're up yeah
yeah I have nothing to say oh okay yeah
so uh so so I get there and at this
point I know I know I left late okay but
the thing is I woke up early I just
couldn't decide where I wanted to hike
that day so it took me a while it's hard
as you do I'm like what the [ __ ] so
anyway so I go on this hike and I'm like
wow like this is so beautiful like you
have to like the whole the whole theme
of like the entire time like that I
couldn't stop saying was like Wow nature
like wow you gonna show me some
beautiful shots yes I am going to show
you guys some beautiful photos show me
how worth it it was it sounds easy he
sounds like an Angry Dad just hearing
the story what the [ __ ] does that have
to do with me in my life I know hold on
Joe's like I don't get interrupt but
everybody else does
I'm being polite okay uh I should have I
should have used all Trails but I did
not so okay so here here's
here's the at the beginning can you send
these photos later we want to share it
with our fans yeah yeah just don't go
too much left there you go very good
that's cool and then that's a great
selfie Joe's like I got photos from
Waikiki you're very brave to go by
yourself though I think I didn't think
so I thought I thought it was just
normal no that's very brave I wouldn't
be normal because the dangerous part
about it is if a rattlesnakes bite you
in your ass there's nobody else with you
do you carry a knife or anything on you
no no no or if you break your goddamn
ankle for not wearing the right shoe
but she's got her Hydro pad Julia we
can't lecture you anymore Julia just
tell us about it look I'm alive okay
guys I'm alive that is the most
awesome I don't want anyone to lecture
you look at how [ __ ] beautiful nature
is Playhouse nature oh my God how about
your team Julia I'm on your team bro
turn it down yeah now I know where the
holes came from the wall God damn dude
it wasn't for me is this going on
patreon now
uh yeah so beautiful so beautiful so
beautiful okay so I'm like walking and
the inner cross country person in me
always like sees inner cross country
yeah because like because for me I'm
just like yo these people are having a
hard time on this Trail I'm gonna give
them a little word of encouragement be
like yeah you're doing such a great job
wise like wow great job guys like you
can do it you know on this like because
Positive Vibes yeah very very positive
right so like I'm I'm like walking up
and man my cardio [ __ ] sucks because
every time I go up a hill I take three
steps I'm like I gotta pull over I gotta
like stop yeah I haven't been across
country no I have again for years
drinking coffee and just hanging out
here eating her mind is cross-country
but her body it's been a minute it's
been a minute yeah yeah so then so
okay so like um I like come across like
this portion of um the trail where I'm
like okay cool I see like a little bit
of like the lake you can't really see it
that's beautiful like a little bit of
the lake but here's the thing though
like I have to get all the way over here
to this ocean to this like little
Lookout Point why right here because
that is that that is oh that's the final
Point that's that's yeah that's where
the trail will take but that looks like
you got a mountain climb to get he's
worried bro he's like oh I'm like girl I
don't know if you that ain't gonna be no
two hours she doesn't engage time very
well it's okay that's that's two hours
if you don't stop speaking of picking up
the pace let's go 30 less details and
then what happens
it kills you need the details these are
important okay these are important okay
so I see a link and I'm like cool wow
this lake is so beautiful right Wow
nature and then I get yeah and then I
get up to the part where it's like a
little flat area and you just see a
whole bunch of trees right I was like
wow this is like so pretty and then all
of a sudden as I get up there right this
guy was like Hey excuse me can you like
take a look at my neck like I kind of
bug bite and I was like and I was like
uh sure and he like leans over and he's
like oh do you like see a stinger or
anything like that I'm like looking at
it I'm like I don't really see anything
but like I got ointment if you want like
to help like keep the swelling down and
like have the bugs repel away that's
tight and he was like oh yeah sure I'll
take it and I was like sure so I like
puts him on him and then he was like oh
yeah so like what brings you out here
and I was like oh I just want to go on a
hike you know I'm here for a
bachelorette party and as soon as I said
that I was like [ __ ] why did I [ __ ]
say that [ __ ] and then I was like I
guess I gotta commit to it and he was
like oh cool yeah like I'm here from
like Seattle
um and he's like okay well like I'll see
you up there and I was like okay and
like I'm just chilling in that one area
like taking photos of the trees and
everything like that but do you have
like the little red guy inside your head
that's like
stranger danger all the [ __ ] time
that's where I pull my knife out yeah
and so I get I get to the top did you
record him oh yeah yeah he's in this
recording I'll show you oh smart Okay so
I get up to the top right and then um
okay I see the bug bite huh no no I
don't I don't have have I don't have a
picture of a bug bite but like as soon
as I get up there like he's the first
person I see this is him right here very
Jeffrey Dahmer Dude Looks like he has
regular clothes on what the [ __ ] I'm
drinking a PBR [ __ ] that would have been
my first [ __ ] like red flag I was
like dude we have jeans on what's going
on this is a hike this is a four hour
hike where's your hydro pack yeah dude
which exactly which retro pack no water
why you got a shovel yeah
why are you looking like you're doing
construction look at this view look at
this view what's that syringe for
right so pocket of pills why so I'm at
the I'm at the lookout top or the tower
right he joins me later and he's like
taking photos and he was like yeah you
know like apparently like this isn't the
end of the trail and I was like oh here
we go like house is not the end of the
trail and two other guys overheard then
they're like what this is the end of the
trail and he's like yeah like it's like
those little Cliffs over there that like
you have to climb because like okay yeah
yeah yeah I know and then so the two
guys that like overheard they're like we
gotta go and I'm like yeah we gotta go
oh my God it's the [ __ ] principle I
did not fly all the way [ __ ] out here
to not complete the hike
yes Queen yes so it is kind of Rocky
right and like so we're all heading in
that direction and this guy like that
that had the bug bite his name is Sean
and so um I like I looked behind me and
he like disappears
for sure so now you're hanging out with
the two guys yeah yeah so I'm following
these two guys and then Sean disappears
behind me I'm like where the [ __ ] did he
go and I was like Sean and then he's
like yeah and I'm like are you okay and
he's like oh yeah I I'm just taking
photos and I was like he's pooping
that's a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] yeah and I was
like all right well like we'll see you
over there right and like I get there
the two guys and I were just hanging out
they're like also Seattle like locals
and they're like all right we'll see you
later right everybody leaves you alone
so they leave you by yourself yeah yeah
yeah and I'm just like chilling on this
Cliff right and like I I already packed
lunch I was like perfect I'm gonna go
eat lunch here
back uh I packed upon me
yeah I packed the bunny yeah the
sandwich you bought this in Seattle yeah
yeah right before I left for my trip
takes a bite
perfect opportunity
oh [ __ ] yes I feel like we're there with
you yeah so like I'm like pretty much
there for like at least like I broke a
dude
40 minutes but like yeah see look at me
yeah
yeah that's our only fans right there
dude mukbangs right so bombers I'm
enjoying my time right and like I'm at
least there for like 40 minutes and the
entire time Sean wasn't even coming up
and I was like all right I guess he
probably just [ __ ] left right and I
was like it's like it's not for everyone
right so this is like my path back right
so this is the lookout place that's the
lookout house that's the lookout house
right whoa so I'm walking back right and
then all of a sudden I see Sean sitting
off to the side just looking out into
the yeah and I was like why Shawn's like
I thought you left right because he
didn't even show up to the cliff part
and he was like oh yeah I just felt
responsible because I told you that this
was in the end of the trail and like
that was the end of the trail and I just
want to make sure that you were okay and
I was like then why did he go with you
yeah so so then I was like all right oh
he was saying that he was like too old
and [ __ ] and like how old is Sean I
I don't know I'm guessing I'm guessing
he's like probably 31. what color too
old yeah excuse me dirty one gross oh
well no he was saying he was too old to
climb the [ __ ] rocks at 30 31. did
you say [ __ ] I'm older than you you
think I'm younger I think that was a
line and you didn't even notice it he's
like I'm 31. so responsible I have a
house but I'm so old dude that's so much
money now because I'm so old and
responsible the entire time I was
literally on a roller coaster because I
just didn't know what to make out like
because like he just seemed like a dude
that he either he was lonely looking for
friends or he was gonna [ __ ] murder
me like I had no idea and honestly no
Hate to this guy but like it was just up
and down right so then after he told me
that like uh yeah I was just like
waiting for you he was like oh I also
took a picture of you and I was like
weird okay
did he show you the picture that he took
of you yeah yeah
picture of you and he air dropped you
air dropped you I don't have an iPhone
isn't that an iPhone that you're holding
no oh that's not an iPhone it's not nice
so what did you do text it to you yeah
yeah so you gave him your number and no
no no and so like if you zoom in closely
that's me right there at the top of the
cliff okay very nice that's kind of a
cool pick though so you had to give him
your name yeah so he's so so then so he
was like okay yeah like you know like I
can send it to you if you like and I was
like yeah sure and I just keep walking I
didn't really tell him anything I just
like Not Really Gonna engage in that
subject right so while I'm glocking I'm
like so what are you gonna do now right
he was like I'm thinking about like
staying here like watching the sunset I
live here well actually I live here and
I was like okay cool I was like I'm
gonna go because me and nighttime are
big no no so uh I'm leaving right and
like make my way and then he continues
to follow me and I was like oh are you
not like staying he was like I you could
catch the sunset by the lake and I was
like okay and then I'm just like walking
at this point and then like I'm getting
to know him like he's been in the Navy
for like 11 years okay this sounds like
the plot of Rambo yeah I'm just getting
really ramble right now here I live here
I'm gonna fight the soldiers right now
yeah like Navy and 11 like for like 11
years and I think he's been in like the
medical field for like a year or two but
like he wants to like sounds like this
guy thinks he's on a date with you I
have no idea but look again again I
don't want to [ __ ] assume okay but
also I want to know did he have a chance
no
poor guy he doesn't play video games you
never stood a chance all right that
picture didn't do a damn thing oh my
goodness glory is that a focus whack is
line you can use oh he's got a picture
of you this will definitely do it
do you like the picture and she'll give
you a far far away oh my goodness
yeah no yeah no glasses
oh no glasses oh boy oh geez Chalmer
summer my name is Sean damn it he talks
to himself damn it Sean put it together
pull it together Sean yeah um
go ahead yeah so then
so then I was like oh uh so I was like
oh that you know I was calling like his
family like immigrated over here like
from America and [ __ ] like uh to America
and whatnot and then I was like all
right all right neat right and then uh
Sri Lanka oh he's Sri Lankan he's what
for long oh my God sorry can you ask me
that again maybe I shouldn't disclose
some of your details about him why not
why
you're back yeah but the way he went
about it was a little creepy we could
all agree right maybe it's just a
critical awareness an era is all you
know and also as a lady you gotta keep
your [ __ ] head on swivel you can't
take any chances yeah you you also it's
either like getting to know you or
murder is in their spectrum of like
thinking and you're in the middle
[ __ ] nowhere and you've been on JK
you've seen some of these [ __ ]
stories we covered and also you didn't
have no pepper spray no nothing what
kind of woman are you
the one that was just focused on going
on a hike all right sorry she's really
good at running oh yeah there's been
many instances where she had to run into
a bush and stuff because people are
gonna kidnap but the stamina issue so
yeah yeah true back then she was
actually cross-country yeah she had a
hydro pack
yeah which will weigh her down so anyway
so Sean's from Sri Lanka and she just
had a sandwich so you know that would
have been you know and his social
security number is Sean you're a cool
dude you're a cool dude okay but spoiled
the end of the story now
getting to know him and he gets like to
know me just a little bit but he's not
like asking me like super personal
questions like oh he knows that I'm in
LA and I work remotely but he never know
like what exactly I worked in or like
where exactly I live so it was like very
casual and he was like showing me like
he was telling me he's like oh yeah you
can probably hike here you probably hike
her or you could probably visit these
things like if you guys are here like
for a bachelorette that's like you seem
genuine yeah give me like suggestions
right and then
um you know like he was like tell me
he's like you know what's so funny and I
was like what he's like I don't even
like hikes and I was like oh my God okay
that's like what are you doing here on a
six and a half mile height then I was
about to kill myself [ __ ] okay yeah
and then and then he was like he was
like yeah um oh cause we were mentioning
about how he was in the Navy and how he
would like travel to different countries
and stuff I know right traveling
different countries so he was saying
that next year he wanted to go to like
Iceland and he also wanted to go to
Nepal and he wanted to do the exhibition
at Nepal so he was like building up a
stamina but he doesn't like hikes yeah
yeah I know that's why I was like why
the [ __ ] you want to see the world
though yeah I mean yeah so then we get
to the lake right and then I was like
all right cool like so you're gonna stay
here and watch the sunset he was like
she's kind of getting a little dark like
and at this point it's already like uh
maybe like
six five yeah probably like around six
right and he was like yeah maybe I
should just like yeah I'll just walk
back with you and I'm like all right
well where's his car huh where's his car
so we're walking we're probably gonna
ask for a ride so we're walking through
and he was like oh yeah can I get your
Instagram by the way so I can like send
you the photo and like my brain was just
like pending the whole time because I
was like Instagram I'm like oh should I
give him my Instagram because like I
think I was like I feel like I always
get weirded out when people ask me for
my Instagram just in general because I'm
like because you famous because you got
a sick follow-up I gave him my full name
my SSN my address but not my Instagram
no so I thought you were getting
comfortable he says can I follow you
back to the car I'm like I would have
been like no dude yeah 10 Paces behind
sir so like I think like he saw that and
he was like actually maybe I can just
give you my Instagram and I was like
okay yeah sure so I like handed my phone
and he like types in his handle I'm like
okay cool and so we're just walking and
then
um he like cracks his neck like yeah
he was like and he was like oh right and
like I didn't know what was going on
because I was walking in front of him
yeah transform into a weirdo and I was
like are you okay and he was like oh
yeah I just cracked my neck oh [ __ ] it's
a full moon tonight
actually it's getting kind of dark yeah
I thought it was gonna be like Steve
Urkel turned into Stefan like what's up
it just became like a cool guy like oh
[ __ ] you got sexy at night you should
have sled with that dude sure that was
Stefan Stefan yeah on the werewolf and
so then like um uh so yeah like he
cracks his neck and then he was like oh
yeah that feels really good and I was
like oh okay and then he's like yeah but
my bug bite is still hurting though and
I was like can you kiss it to make it go
away I need to suck it yeah
and then and then I was like oh I think
I might have like some allergy pills
like do you want that and then he was
like yeah sure I'll like I'll take it
and so I give him an allergy pill and he
was like wow you're really prepared and
I was like I feel like I kind of have to
be if I'm gonna be hiking he's like
you're really prepared do you have any
pepper spray no yeah
so then here's the thing he was saying
like oh the only thing I brought was
bear spray and two things came across my
mind I was like Hairspray and I was like
I never thought I would encounter bear
at a national park which I probably
should have considered and then the
other part would be like is bear spray
like a like a souped-up version of
pepper spray and I'm like and am I gonna
die is he gonna spray me when he said
that I was like oh okay and so I didn't
want to think about it and I was like yo
man like that's cool like have you ever
seen sun bears and he was like a sun
bear and I was like yeah man they're
like one of the saddest looking
creatures on this planet like you should
look them up sometime
so sad you wouldn't want to spray them
yeah yeah and I was like yeah sun bears
and he's like nah I don't know anything
about them and so then he was saying
like yeah you know if I encounter a bear
like I'm prepared right and I was like
what do you mean and he was like yeah I
got a knife too and he like flashes it
on his backpack and I'm like oh my God I
was like of course he would because you
were a navy and then a part of me was
like oh my God if I gotta die tonight
because he just fly because I was like
the entire time he was doing so well in
conversation and then all of a sudden he
tells me about bear spray and showing
his knife and I'm like
this is this is the end of and for you
your biggest distraction for him to do
that was a [ __ ] sun bear
he's like I'm gonna distract his mind he
was like about to pull the gun out like
here we're here to Sun Bear sun bear
I have not what do you mean talk to me
more about this
you're like she was like um I have a
question you ever heard of a sun bears
is it like a caravan it's just like huh
you really [ __ ] up my mind I was
thinking it's just funny that this guy's
just prepared he has a knife and bear
spray which is totally normal for a hike
yeah right right but can also be used
for like murder yeah yeah different kind
of prepare and instead of being like yo
I have this just in case because I can
protect you she's like oh my God I need
protection now I don't know Sean I know
your true intentions dude I know what
the [ __ ] is okay this is very weird dude
no but like see but then like see I
didn't want to think that poorly of him
because I was like I don't know like
this these are just like standard things
you know so like that's why I talked
about sun bears because like I gotta get
my mind off of that and like I need to
talk about something like a little
lighter or whatever and like I think
that's how hikers flirt yeah I have no
idea either way I was like oh my God why
would you like [ __ ] do that like I
was feeling okay I was like yeah you
know what maybe this is just like a
chill dude and then when you splash the
knife I'm like oh please like yeah
that's like a hiker's pickup line I have
the biggest knife here that's a big
[ __ ] knife but he was
he was saying like the biggest [ __ ]
knife I've seen
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] but he was basically saying like
I'm not gonna go down with the fight if
I fight a bear
that's what it sounds like to me he's
trying to hit on you and then he's
crying so hard basic macking or if I
have to I'll carry you my [ __ ] you
know on the shoulder and when I said I
was like look man if I get attack of a
bear and if I die I die if I live I live
like like that is just like how my life
would be you made peace wow okay now
this guy's got a raging boner and then
what happens yeah I know right yeah get
them all hot and bothered dude yeah so
then
um yeah so we're just like walking I'm
like okay I'm Not Really Gonna think
about that then we talk about dogs and
then we get to the point of this Lake
again like at the starting point and he
was like oh yeah I even brought a kayak
and I was like
okay
how did that he's like hold on let me
take it out of my ass
holy [ __ ] dude so what happened after
the kayak oh no nothing like he had it
was in his car and I was like saying
like oh maybe you can just go ahead and
like kayak into the middle of the lake
you're trying to get rid of them you're
like you should go well like I don't
know I was just like uh I don't wanna
you wanna keep it cool yeah cute cool so
we get to the end of the trail and he
was like okay cool like well like
where's your car I'll walk you to your
car and I was like nah it's that way and
he was like me too and I'm like no it's
not you're like just kidding it's that
way huh it's at the parking lot he goes
me too I've got two cars here but but he
honestly
he honestly did have his car over there
and we were like 20 feet away and then
he like just dropped me off in my car
and he was like well wait so you got in
the car with them no no no no I'm saying
20 feet away our cars are 20 feet away
from each other because you said dropped
off and I'm like he walked you to oh
okay car 20 feet away damn girl you're
just saying at the end of it he was just
a nice guy yeah pretty much
hey Julia [ __ ] these guys dude that was
a great story
we'll be ready I'm ready for the nice
story I wanted some action I did one
I wanted to be more like [ __ ] shut up
get in the car hey Sundance sun bears
are cool so embarrassed anyway dude so I
saw a Sunbury one second
what the hell is wrong with you
honestly I never even knew there was a
thing called a sunburn neither and I I
feel like I know bears and I feel like
now that's the perfect out for any
conversation thank you for the most
perfect story
there's there's a little bit more to it
though there's a little bit more no I'm
done I'm done
there's a little more to it yeah that's
because there's a sun bear oh yeah
I'm sorry I bet it's gonna end with
Eddie try to kill me and then it shuts
off and I'm like what the [ __ ] start
with that start with that yeah no so
like so I was dude that was me like when
I [ __ ] wake up from a hangover that's
not okay fine [ __ ] the bear keep going
we're running out of time all right all
right I'm gonna let you wrap this up
yeah yeah yeah so basically I'm I'm like
driving I'm driving away I get off the
PA like I get off the gravel I'm on
payment pavement my car says I have low
tire pressure I call a friend I'll be
like hey should I pull over or can I
make it to my friend's house and they're
like you should [ __ ] pull over so I
pull over to the gas station it was just
like me and like two other cars or
whatever I go in and like I try to like
get like the air like pump or whatever
immediately smoke comes out of the tire
and it looks like the sidewall was like
uh damaged so I like slashed by a knife
that he had
up under
it was from the gravels from the gravel
damn it oh Jesus
I know
he sounds like oh my oh that's normal
yeah exactly exactly and then eventually
uh yeah like there was some random
stranger that was cleaning out his car
and like he had a bunch of trash bags in
the back of his car and he was like do
you need help and I was like and that's
the guy that tried to rob you yes I do
need help and so he changed my tire for
me and I was like making small talk and
I was like Hey so like what are you
doing here and he's like oh yeah me and
my buddy were just hanging out but now
we're just figuring out what to do and I
was like okay that's cool uh I'm
assuming you had like plenty of flats in
your lifetime he was like yeah a lot of
flat tires I was like yeah but you know
like this is how you change the tire I
was like cool well I really appreciate
you changing out my tire like honey like
should you do meal or like you know give
you some money and you'll be like yeah
that'd be great so I was like cool I
gave him the money and then I was like
by the way
um I don't like I still have like half a
sandwich and some like swish blueberries
do you want that he was like yeah girl
take it and so he like took that and he
was like yeah have a great night it's a
barter yeah and then I was like Hey that
that that sandwich has a jalapeno I
don't know how your spice tolerance is
and he was like oh no man me my
girlfriend like like I got a Thai
girlfriend we eat spices all the time
that was it what a great story Julian
that was great that was for me
yeah that was it
sorry maybe unsatisfactory hey guys be
Sports come on come on clean cloud
[Applause]
yay